[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICHOLAS CLINTON:
Hello, everybody.
My name's Nick Clinton--
Earth Engine
developer relations.
And we're going to
talk to you today,
about a project to map
global land cover at higher
resolution than ever before.
And specifically,
what I mean by that
is mapping the land cover
in each 30 meter patch
of the Earth back to 2013.
So this is a very
ambitious project.
And this kind of a global land
cover time series has never
been done before.
So Earth Engine teamed up
with Cloud to make it happen,
and we're going to tell you how.
But first, you
might be wondering--
what is land cover?
And the analogy that I like
to use is what's on the shelf?
And so organizations
all over the world--
governments, NGOs, nonprofits,
researchers, businesses--
want to understand the literal
landscape in which they're
doing business.
So here is a more formal
definition of land
cover-- it's the observed
physical cover of the Earth's
surface, which describes
the distribution
of vegetation
types, water bodies,
and human-built environments,
and other land cover types.
That distribution is a map.
And so here's a
map of the imagery
that I showed you a
couple slides ago--
or rather, the pixels
are turned into a map.
And we'd like to
do this at scale.
And do it not only for the
whole surface of the world,
but for a time series.
And when you have a time
series of maps like that,
you can start to
understand processes, like,
the change in crop land,
urbanization, deforestation,
the change in water resources
in your area of interest.
And these are not
just buzz words.
Land cover is, in fact,
codified into the UN Sustainable
Development Goals.
So Google is interested in
helping to achieve these goals.
And one of the key ingredients
to making that happen
is just monitoring
and understanding
where you are at a given time.
And so that's why we
need maps like this.
In order to get a lot
of these at global scale
and a time series of them, we
need to use a lot of imagery.
And we need to use
a lot of imagery
to turn all those pixels
into land cover labels--
like you see in this map.
So fortunately, we have
Earth Engine to help you
with that kind of thing.
And what is Earth Engine?
Earth Engine is
Google's Cloud platform
for geospatial processing.
And it's got a whole
bunch of good stuff--
primarily raster data.
So lots of satellite imagery,
but other geospatial data sets,
as well.
And here's an example.
This is the same image
that you saw before.
This is Landsat 8, which is the
latest and greatest Landsat.
Landsat 9 is coming.
But we want to turn
all these pixels--
and we are right up
there, somewhere--
we want to turn all
these pixels into labels.
So we have not only images
like that Landsat image,
but we've got lots
of other raster
and other geospatial
data sets that
are useful for making
those kind of maps.
So we have all of Landsat, all
of Sentinel from the European
Space Agency, lots
of Modus data,
land cover data terrain
data, climate and weather
data, so on and so forth.
50 plus petabytes of
data in the Earth Engine
catalog and growing daily,
as more scenes come in.
All that data is not useful
without a computation platform.
So the data archive is
co-located with Google scale
resources to do computation.
And that's what
you need in order
to tackle big machine
learning problems
like making time series of
those maps all over the world.
And to tell you more
about the machine learning
part of this project is Chris.
Take it away, Chris.
CHRISTOPHER BROWN:
Thank you, Nick.
Hi, my name is
Chris Brown, and I'm
an engineer on Earth Engine.
So you're going to hear
a lot about this today.
And I'm not going to
be the first person
to talk about machine
learning tools at Google.
But we do need to talk about
them here, specifically.
Because to produce
this map, it's
a more complicated process than
just adding and subtracting
some pixels.
We actually have to have a
little bit of intelligence
to do this.
So a brief word on some of
the tools we have to build up
something like this.
We could start with
Collab and TensorFlow--
you all know TensorFlow.
Collab, being an IPython
notebook environment
that's free, provided
by Google that
has things like TensorFlow
and GPU back ends.
So we could train
our model this way,
we could build a model this way.
We can then start to scale
our predictions using things
like ML Engine, Kubernetes.
There's an extreme end,
we won't talk about today.
But if you're an app
developer and you
don't need to create your own
model-- like we did-- you do
have things like speech
translate and other APIs
built-in.
But what we're
going to talk about
is how we used things like
TensorFlow, Collab, and then
AI platform to make this
land cover map happen.
So to build a good
model-- in our case,
we want to model land cover--
we need a couple of things.
We need big data.
And Nick was talking
about this 50 petabytes
and growing of data
in Earth Engine.
We need good models--
this is something that's
brought to bear by TensorFlow.
And then we need a
ton of computation--
some of which is
on Earth Engine.
But we can't do it
all in Earth Engine,
and we'll get to
that in a little bit.
So we understand this is a
machine learning problem.
We understand this is
a big data problem.
But we need to talk about why.
So if we think for a
second, about land cover--
we can also get a
little more specific
and talk about land use.
So if we think about
land cover being
what stuff is made of on
the surface of the Earth--
we could use the example of
a parking lot and a road.
They're both made of
asphalt, presumably.
And if all you knew was that
this is made of asphalt--
the way we do it is
with reflectance,
but bear with me here--
we know material,
could you tell the difference?
You can't, right?
It doesn't just matter
what something is made of,
it's the arrangement of
what it's made of in space.
And so this
transforms our problem
of identifying land cover from
looking at a single pixel,
looking at reflectance
saying, oh, I
know what this is to looking at
many, many pixels, and saying,
we know what this is.
Because we don't just need to
know the reflectances-- a.k.a.
the material at
one point-- we need
to know how that's
arranged in space.
So this turns this
machine learning problem
into a much heavier problem.
Our input stopped being
something like red,
green, blue-- or in our
case, because they're
satellites-- red, green,
blue, ultraviolet, infrared,
and a bunch of other stuff.
To red, green,
blue, ultraviolet,
infrared for 64 by 64 or
greater patches of pixels--
that's a ton of input data.
And the question is, do we have
the tools to work with this?
And the answer is we do.
Earth Engine today-- if
you didn't already know--
does have interoperability
with TensorFlow.
So you can start to
take these images that
have spatial context
or temporal contexts
and make predictions about them.
Or run inference
over these images.
And this works great, and
well, why don't we stop here?
We're done, that should be it.
The problem is you can do
this over a small region.
You can run TensorFlow on
your machine over these images
and make predictions.
But things get tricky
when you want to scale it.
This is an image where--
as Nick was describing--
30 meters per pixel.
This is of the United States.
And is actually 500 megapixels
or so-- something like that.
And yes, sure, these
aren't just 500 megapixels.
These are 500
megapixels over which,
a fully convolutional
neural net--
if you know what that is--
was applied at scale.
And it was done in
about two hours--
which is amazing.
Because-- bringing this
back to land cover maps--
these are things that
historically take five years
to build for one year.
And once we talk about
scaling up our ability
to apply inference--
it's a big data problem.
This isn't just an Earth
Engine large catalog problem,
this is an Earth Engine
with a big catalog,
with a big computation problem.
And to actually
scale these types
of predictions
over the world, we
have to get a
little bit smarter.
And David is going to
tell us how we got smarter
using Cloud Platform.
DAVID CAVAZOS: So now that
we had a trained model,
we need to do
predictions at scale.
So the Earth is big,
it's really big.
And we have Landsat 8 satellite
images for the entire world,
for every 16 days since 2013
at that 30 meter resolution--
that's a lot of data.
So how do we do
these predictions
at scale with so much data?
First, we have to subdivide
the world into smaller regions.
Now, the cool thing is that
every individual region
is independent from
each other so they
can be running parallel.
So, let's say, we want to
classify this location.
The first step will
be identifying which
region contains this location.
And then, we can run
the classification only
on that region.
So let's look into more
detail at how we do this.
First, we have an App
Engine server into which,
we submit that location.
And then it computes the
bounds of the region that
contains that
location, which is then
submitted into Earth Engine.
Earth Engine now
extracts this region,
and it gets stored
in the Cloud Storage.
So this is how the Landsat 8
image looks like, or at least,
that's what our eyes can see.
This is the RGB
representation of it.
And it's kind of hard
to tell what is what.
Everything looks kind
of greenish so we don't
know if it's exactly, like,
grassland, or forest, or even
water.
Fortunately, Landsat 8 comes
with very sophisticated sensors
that can see a broader range
of the electromagnetic spectrum
that our eyes cannot see, such
as infrared and even thermal
information.
And all of these
gives a signature
to each of material that
makes it easier for our model
to identify what kind of
material is within each pixel.
So as we can see now in these
other bands of the non-visible
spectrum--
things like water and
concrete stand out a lot more
than in the previous image.
So as these Landsat images
are extracted, parts of them
are written into Cloud Storage.
As these files are written,
they trigger a Cloud Function
that does a request to a
Kubernetes cluster running
our TensorFlow model
to do the predictions.
And these predictions
are at a file level.
And once there are
classified, they
are now stored, once
again, into Cloud Storage.
This is what the prediction
for that area looks like.
And as we can see,
every single pixel
has a value for one out
of 10 possible classes.
As these land cover files are
written into Cloud Storage,
those trigger another
Cloud Function
that tells our server to
upload that image back
into Earth Engine.
Where it gets stored
into an image collection,
which contains the
land cover maps
for the entire world for all
the years that we've extracted.
Now, these land cover maps are
very useful for decision makers
and other organizations to
make more informed decisions
about what resources
are in the Earth.
And every pixel tells a
story, especially when
we see the change.
Now, one of the very cool
things about Earth Engine
is that once the data
is in Earth Engine,
it's not only visible
within Earth Engine.
But it's also accessible to
other external applications,
which made it possible for
us to build a custom web
application using
AngularJS and Maps
API to request both the land
cover images and the landscape
images.
And then, render them
into our application.
So let's take a look
at some locations.
Here, we are in Cambodia.
What we can see here--
as the dark green--
that's forest.
And all that amber-yellowish
thing-- that's farmland.
And if you pay attention to the
central region of that forest--
if we turn on the animation
from 2013 to 2018,
we can see how the
farmland is slowly eating
through this protected land.
Land cover makes it
easier to quantify.
But we choose the
Landsat images,
then we can clearly see how
this is affecting some very
important habitats in Cambodia.
Now we can go into the Amazon.
This is Peru.
And we see this thing that
looks kind of like a river that
is going down.
And if we turn the
animation on, then we'll
see a very interesting
thing-- that this
is growing and flowing, as if
a new river was being created.
Well, this is not
actually a river.
This is toxic waste and
heavy metal residues
coming from a mine nearby.
Fortunately, some
researchers in Peru
are looking at trees
and plant species that
can grown in these
hazardous environments
to help clean up the area.
And now if we go all
the way in Iran--
this is Lake Urmia, the
largest lake in Iran.
And we can see how the
water levels is decreasing.
And this is due to the
construction of dams
and the effects
of global warming.
In fact, that little green patch
that we see nearby the water--
that used to be an island
surrounded by water.
So as we can see, these land
cover maps tell us a story.
And have a lot of very
insightful information
about the regions
that help us quantify
what's happening in there.
But they take a lot of time
and effort to create these.
In fact, to create a
map of the entire USA,
it takes at least five years
to create one of these.
So we tried generating the maps
for the entire United States,
and we managed to get the
maps from 2013 to 2018,
in under 24 hours.
So let me show you a
quote from Mahatma Gandhi.
"What we are doing to
the forests in the world
is but a mirror
reflection of what
we are doing to ourselves
and to one another."
But it's not all bad news.
There is also, a bunch
of very cool efforts
that are happening
around the world.
Well, something's not working--
there we go.
So for example, this is the
Great Green Wall project
that is happening in Africa.
this is in conjunction with a
bunch of different countries
and communities
working together,
to plant a lot of trees
and edible plants.
To create a division between
the now growing Sahara Desert,
and protect the
forests in Africa.
And there are also some
reforestation efforts
in the Amazon, where
people are gathering seeds
from the forests around them
and then mixing them with soil
and planting in affected areas.
Here, we can see
how these plants
look like after three to
six months of growing.
And then these trees--
after five to seven
years of growing.
We all share the same planet.
And every little action-- like,
using less plastic or growing
your own food--
will have an impact.
If you like this
project or would
like to see how it was created,
you can follow this link.
And it'll take you
to our GitHub repo.
Or you're can share
this story in Medium.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]